es geht um den neuen film von damien
schüssel aufbruch zum mond die erzählung
die nacherzählung der ersten und
amerikanischen mondexpeditionen als 69
und das wort nacherzählung macht auch
schon deutlich dass es ein großes
problem gibt bei diesem film und das ist
wenn man sich diesen film anschaut vom
ersten moment weiß man wieder ausgeht
das heißt jeder es gibt diese legendären
satz von von ihnen angst als er den mond
betritt ein kleiner schritt für mich ein
großer schritt für die menschheit und
dass der ganze film darauf zu läuft ist
eigentlich klar
und deswegen fragt man sich von anfang
an wie kann dieser film eigentlich
spannung erzeugen wenn man sofort das
ende schon weiß
ernste probleme
es ist kein film der bombastisch
monumental auf alles aufhört was ist so
ein technik und so weiter geht ist es
sehr historisch genau also stelle hat
sich sehr sehr interessiert für die
details dieser raumfahrt mission und die
abläufe akribisch lebensweise
rekonstruiert und so dass er keine
spannung jetzt im herkömmlichen sinne
aufbaut dass man permanent irgendwie
offenem mund da sitzt aber man wird
langsam hineingeführt in diese ganzen
abläufe und natürlich auch die
unglaublichen risiken die diese
mondexpeditionen hatte die richtige
fehler macht wir müssen die fehler auf
der erde machen und nicht später darauf
rein gosling hat sichtbar
schwierigkeiten sich in diese figur
hineinzudenken und sie auszufüllen also
neil armstrong war sicherlich so wie man
das ist im film erfährt ein schwieriger
mensch ein absolut nach außen hin
relativ verschlossener rein auf die auf
diese mission konzentrierter typ der
eben ein schweres schicksal erlitten hat
seine tochter damit beginnt auch der
film ist eben an krebs gestorben und
diesen schmerz über den verlust dieser
tochter den frisst er in sich hinein
er macht nach außen hin zu und sozusagen
transformiert das große unglück das
unheil was mir das widerfahren es eben
in diese große mission dieser dieser
mond mund und wir haben die feste
absicht wieder zu kommen
vielleicht schafft ihr es nicht viel
glück diese völlige unterkühlung dies
natürlich braucht um so einen
wahnsinnigen und auch völlig
unwahrscheinliche missionen zu
überstehen
die drückt der gosling sehr gut aus es
ist aber das muss man sagen für gosling
fans ist es jetzt nicht eine rolle wo
man alle facetten und alle register
sieht die dieser schauspieler sonst so
zu ziehen hat nicht er ist ein sehr
zurückhaltender und eben käufer spieler
da ich weiß nicht was die
weltraumforschung uns für erkenntnisse
bringt aber keinesfalls wird es nur eine
forschung um der forschung wählen sein
ich denke es wird darum gehen dass wir
dadurch dinge sehen die wir vielleicht
schon längst hätten sehen sollen
aber uns bisher einfach verschlossen
waren
es ist eben eine eigentlich schon der
geheimnisvollste film von joel bisher
weil es geht eben darum warum hat man so
ein interesse an diesem montag hat der
mensch diese vorstellung ist der mond
erobert werden muss ja wahr was ist das
eigentlich ist eben nicht nur eine
wissenschaftliche angelegenheit ja
obwohl sie das immer noch außen sind
sagen es ist am ende auch nicht nur eine
politische angelegenheit gegen die
russen sondern es geht um die eine
tiefere existenzielle frage nämlich wer
sind wir und gibt es noch
energieausweise höhere instanzen und
können wir das herausfinden ob es diese
höheren instanzen wenn der flug gelingt
gehen sie in die geschichte ein
was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn die
in der gedanke kommt der güte an
der flug wird einer vor wir planen dass
der flug ein erfolg wird deswegen ist es
ein film für alle die ein interesse
daran haben zu sehen was der mensch als
mensch gemacht hat wozu er im besten und
vielleicht eben auch im fragwürdigsten
sinne fähig ist nämlich immer diese
sehnsucht nach dem anderen nach dem
unverstandenen und dem
grenzüberschreitenden solarmodule and
anflug
[Musik]